yes sir what a pleasure it is to meet
you here in to resume your own sound
compliment you will be one of the
speakers at kalixa Scotland's waiting
for the barbarians and we will address
the questions at the conference the
first games how come there are still
barbarians and the second is and how
civilized is Western society
now to introduce you to the audience
could do please tell us a little bit
more about yourself who are you with
your background what are you doing my
academic background is not so I did
philosopher language in English okay day
and then I get the master's degree in
islamic studies at sauce loss okay I've
studied this cage
did a short study of Berkeley and also I
work on the container who is one of the
main authorities in what is described by
our Salafi groups of rebels
after that I did my Master's we xos
issue i work on his guitar that is
fighting a war in Quran and the main
reason for me to work or to shift from
philosophy to islamic studies is that i
was thinking i said when i would be able
to come back to Tunisia because I was
not able to come before the Revolution
yeah I said that our problem need not be
conflict with what Matt foreign
securities will be rather with those
youngsters who will not have to Islam so
I need to have tools which will enable
me to import in discussions so can you
tell us more about these tools you
for example also you pain in the
Netherlands and Belgium and you know
Scoob are astonished that they will go
to fight for Islamic state
society
go there
Western civilization party part of it is
is part of this radical way of seeing
the truth is the two values truthful the
exfoliant values that until you are
either true or wrong there is no third
value for the truth this is also one of
the issues the other issue is that even
in the West there are there is a crisis
of values because the West is now
shifting away from the values of the
seventeenth and eighteenth century
humanity
and that human is a second he tried to
sell office Christ canonic crisis the
war which is being waged right now which
is it is bringing a reality which does
not validate values when their political
values or ethical values of the west and
this also push people away from
coherently leaving
so we do have a universal problem which
is not only in our country and I'm not
only the euros not only us it is i think
a universal value which all of us we
need to work together so that we are
inconsistent with our parties everyday
life is not introducting with
the finest olympics in values in the
market values reflect how we manage
content and breaking it out where the
Arab Spring started people are very
useful they thought we will have
democracy
tolerance equal rights it so
we are still struggling but i think we
are building you could say new values
and you are new because we are different
from what we oppressive regime use what
is difference is that exactly does not
generate position it does not tolerate
difference is the same now we can see
that those who would have been enemies
before are working together and they are
different partners at the same
government within the same problem I
mean into musicals we do still have hope
for success of what we might call a
peaceful revolutions and this if we are
successful in it we will do a
breakthrough because one of definitions
of revolution is that it is legitimate
way using violence the main values of
the Tunisian revolution is that it is a
peaceful resolution so we need the
successful
can you turn badly need a success story
which has different values those values
of democracy freakin kiddin and people
who can live together why they are
different and as you can see we are in a
very beautiful country you have to see
here who came as tourists here I
personally am very happy to have you
here and I would like really to have
country thank you